Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的内容之前，我想先向大家预告一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我与商业导师Lisa Johnson共同举办的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. I just wanted to start today's podcast episode by just giving you a little warning that it is going to cover risk. It's going to cover examples of how someone might pose a risk to
这些原则都同样适用。竞赛中还有由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会为你提供所有详细信息。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在开始之前，我想先给出一个小提醒：今天的内容将涉及“风险”话题，包括一个人可能对自己或他人构成风险的案例。
themselves or to others. If you might find this triggering, then please take my permission and give yourself permission to listen to this at a time where you feel more robust and able to um to engage with the con if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. Thank you for listening.
如果你觉得这会引发不适，请务必照顾好自己，选择在你感觉状态更稳健、能够处理这些内容的时候再收听。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么就让这个播客成为你的指南，陪伴你走上获得资格认证的道路。这里是Marianne Trent博士的《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。你好，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》，感谢你的收听。
And I hope you will find today's episode really useful. This is another special request episode today. And you can make any special requests you might have for topics for the podcast by heading to my website, goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast and then there at the top of the page is information for how you can submit any requests that you might have please do because I want this to be super useful for you and yeah I want this to be user led, as well as just being generated by me. Because, you know, knowing that you are recognizing that I might have some useful stuff to teach you, and you reaching out to me to ask, ask for me to teach it to you is just the most incredible
希望你觉得今天的内容非常有用。这是又一期特别请求节目。你可以通过访问我的网站 goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast 提出你对播客主题的任何特别请求。页面顶部有提交请求的相关信息，请务必提交，因为我希望这档节目对你真正有用，我希望它不仅是由我主导，也能由用户引导。因为，知道你们认可我能传授有用的知识，并且主动联系我请求我进行讲解，这真的是一种最不可思议的
feeling. So yeah, thank you very much for all of the feedback that I've had and for continuing to listen. It means a great deal. Just a little caveat before we begin to let you know that the risk I will be talking about is when someone is discussing perhaps risk to themselves or someone else. But don't worry if you want some more tips on practical risk management, because that is coming up soon in an interview I'll be doing with a psychiatrist where we discuss how to kind of optimally prepare the environment and factors to consider about minimising risk to yourself, to colleagues and to clients too. It's also worth saying that when working with risk, it's really important to work collaboratively
感觉。所以，非常感谢大家给予的所有反馈以及持续的收听，这对我意义重大。在开始之前，先做一个小小的说明：我所讨论的风险是指当某人谈论对自己或他人可能构成的风险时的情况。不过别担心，如果你想了解更多关于实际风险管理的技巧，请关注我即将与一位精神科医生进行的访谈，我们将讨论如何优化环境准备，以及在最大限度降低对自己、同事和客户风险时需要考虑的因素。同样值得一提的是，在处理风险时，与你的多学科团队、精神科医生、督导以及团队中的其他成员进行协作是非常重要的。
with your multidisciplinary team and of course with psychiatry and with supervisors and anybody else you might have on board as part of your team. So do take my advice in conjunction with your own best practice guidelines. Okay, so no matter what area of psychology you are wanting to work in, it is likely that you will encounter risk and working with risk as you progress throughout your career. It's certainly something that crops up for me daily in clinical practice, even if just to discuss it, you know, whether it's a current thing for clients or not. Now, of course, when we're working in services, risk can look like risk to themselves. Risk can look like risk to others. It's not really the done thing to define a word by using the word, is it? So let me define risk without using the word risk okay so risk might
因此，请将我的建议与你自己的最佳实践指南结合起来使用。无论你想在心理学的哪个领域工作，随着职业生涯的发展，你很可能会遇到风险，并需要处理风险。这在我的临床实践中确实是每天都会出现的问题，即使只是讨论它，无论它是否是客户当前面临的问题。当然，当我们在服务机构工作时，风险可能表现为对自己构成的风险，也可能表现为对他人的风险。用一个词来定义这个词本身似乎不太合适，对吧？所以，让我试着在不使用“风险”这个词的情况下定义它。好的，那么风险可能
look like someone who wants to self-harm it might look like self-harm that is superficial it might look like self-harm that is more significant it might involve that they have you know perhaps a plan to end their own life you may also be party to information where they're saying that they want to harm someone else and that might be in a forensic service or it might be that you suspect that they are having some sort of psychotic episode or some sort of change. So it might be that people are in, you know, perfect lucid thought telling you that they think, you know, so and so is going to, you know, be hurt. And that, of course, is a significant event that needs to be recorded and needs to be handled with the client at the time. So yeah, you might handle that in a number of different ways. If you haven't already listened
表现为某人想要自残，可能是表层的自残，也可能是更严重的自残；它可能涉及他们有结束自己生命的计划。你也可能获悉他们想要伤害他人的信息，这可能发生在法医服务中，或者你怀疑他们正在经历某种精神病发作或某种状态改变。所以，人们可能在思维完全清晰的情况下告诉你，他们认为某某人将会受到伤害。当然，这是一个重大事件，需要记录在案，并需要在当时与客户进行处理。所以，你可能会以多种不同的方式来处理这种情况。如果你还没有听过
to episode eight of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, then it might be useful for you to do that either before listening to this episode or after. So episode eight is all about boundary setting as an aspiring psychologist. And in that I go through, you know, confidentiality and consent. And that is also really useful stuff to draw upon. So I'm not going to go over all of that content again, because I don't want to, you know, duplicate what I've already said, because you won't find that useful. But I will pay lip service to what I've said. But you might well find it helpful to listen to episode eight if you haven't already, because that is going to be a more full account of what we're talking about here with respect to confidentiality
《有志心理学家播客》的第八期，那么在听本期节目之前或之后去听一下可能会很有用。第八期是关于作为一名有志心理学家如何设定界限的，我在其中讨论了保密和知情同意。这些内容也非常值得参考。所以我不会再重复所有这些内容，因为我不想重复我已经说过的话，那样对你没有帮助。但我会提到我之前说过的内容。如果你还没有听过第八期，你可能会觉得听一下很有帮助，因为它对我们这里讨论的关于保密
and consent. So as you'll know, when we're working with people, we've already gone through our confidentiality and consent. And that is especially useful when you then get issues where risk is cropping up so if someone were to say that they you know wanted to hurt themselves or someone else then you will then obviously respond appropriately in the moment but also think with them about your you know your needing to keep themselves and others safe and that they're aware that you have that duty of care to do that you've got that clinical responsibility that you've got to look after everybody to keep them safe it's a big job guys it's a big job let's take a boat take a moment take a breath it is a big job and it matters and what you're doing matters um but we're here we're in the moment and the client has suggested that they want to to hurt themselves or someone else it can be useful useful to think about time frame. It can be useful. So if, for example, someone has said that they, you know, they've got a plan to end their own life, then it can be useful to think about, well, have you have you got a in mind for a particular time or a particular date and they might well tell you
和知情同意的问题有更全面的说明。如你所知，当我们与人合作时，我们已经完成了保密和知情同意的流程。当出现风险问题时，这一点尤其有用。如果有人说他们想要伤害自己或他人，你显然会当场做出适当的反应，但也要与他们一起思考你需要保护他们及他人安全的问题，并让他们意识到你有履行这种关怀的义务，你有临床责任去照顾每个人并确保他们的安全。这是一项艰巨的工作，伙计们，这是一项艰巨的工作。让我们停下来，深呼吸一下。这是一项艰巨的工作，而且很重要。你所做的事情很重要，我们身处当下，客户表示他们想要伤害自己或他人，思考时间框架可能会很有用。所以，例如，如果有人说他们有结束自己生命的计划，那么思考一下“你是否已经想好了特定的时间或日期”可能会很有用，他们可能会告诉你，
or they might well not and when people are less wanting to share information then it's it's more worrying it can be more worrying obviously this is going to be a case-by-case example and you will definitely need to access supervision of your own about this so please don't just use this advice to formulate your plans but it can be in mind and especially if you're not yet in clinical practice it can be useful for you to think about what would I do what might I do how could I handle? So that's my little caveat. This is a guide, but you will obviously need to follow your own protocols and procedures and check in with your management and your supervisors. So someone has told you that they've got a plan.
也可能不会。当人们不太愿意分享信息时，这会更令人担忧。显然，这将是一个个案，你绝对需要就此寻求你自己的督导，所以请不要仅仅使用这些建议来制定你的计划，但你可以将其记在心里。特别是如果你还没有进入临床实践，思考“我会怎么做？我可能会怎么做？我该如何处理？”是很有用的。这就是我的小提醒。这是一个指南，但你显然需要遵循自己的协议和程序，并与你的管理层和督导进行核对。所以，有人告诉你他们有一个计划。
They perhaps won't share with you what time frame it's going to be, but maybe they have shared with you the method and it's, you know, detailed enough that that feels worrying, you know, that feels scary. And it might be that if it involves harm to someone else that they've shared with you details about what that might involve and what kind of time frame that might take as well and you know it's it's tricky because you're going to be feeling all kinds of things going on you're going to be feeling you know pressure you're going to be feeling um you know, the importance and the significance of getting this right. When I was an aspiring psychologist, certainly sometimes when I was even working as a trainee psychologist,
他们可能不会与你分享时间框架，但也许他们已经与你分享了方法，而且足够详细，这让你感到担忧，让你感到害怕。如果涉及对他人的伤害，他们可能已经与你分享了涉及的内容以及可能需要的时间框架。这很棘手，因为你会感受到各种各样的情绪，你会感到压力，你会感受到把这件事做对的重要性和意义。当我还是一个有志心理学家时，当然，有时甚至当我作为一名实习心理学家时，
if somebody told me that they wanted to end their life, then there might have been a tendency or a desire to run out of the room as soon as possible and kind of get psychiatry involved. But actually, we need to think about how that feels as a client communicating this painful information. And actually, what can be really useful is to work through with the client, you know, what they're thinking and what they're feeling, exploring a little bit about what might have contributed to the way they're feeling and why. Really try to help contain the person you're speaking to so that they feel like they have shared something with you that then feels safe it's not left them feeling over vulnerable or overstretched how you respond and when you respond and with what flavor and tone of compassion and warmth and empathy and positive regard really does matter. You know,
如果有人告诉我他们想结束自己的生命，我可能会有一种想要尽快跑出房间并让精神科介入的冲动。但实际上，我们需要思考作为一名传达这种痛苦信息的客户，他们的感受是什么。实际上，真正有用的是与客户一起梳理他们的想法和感受，探索一下是什么导致了他们的这种感受以及原因。真正尝试去安抚你正在交谈的人，让他们觉得他们与你分享了一些事情，并且感到安全，而不是让他们感到过度脆弱或压力过大。你如何回应、何时回应，以及回应时所带有的同情、温暖、共情和积极关注的语气，确实很重要。你知道，
if we are to run out of the room when someone tells us something like that, then it might actually lead the client to feeling that their problems are too big to cope with, or that they it might lead to them feeling even more you know unsafe or you know less contained and when people are not contained you know what we know is that they're going to be acting from more from a point of you know the red area of their window of tolerance they're not going to be able to engage their soothing and calming thoughts. You know, they're going to be all out of whack. And, you know, logical thought with compassion on their side is not going to be, you know, firing. OK, so what we're wanting to do is we're wanting to help the client feel heard, seen, valid, important. We don't want to be running away.
如果我们因为某人告诉我们这样的事情就跑出房间，那么这实际上可能会导致客户觉得他们的问题太大而无法应对，或者这可能会导致他们感到更加不安全，或者更加缺乏安抚。当人们没有得到安抚时，我们知道他们会更多地从“耐受窗口”的红色区域出发采取行动，他们将无法调动他们的舒缓和冷静的思维。他们会完全失控。而且，带有同情心的逻辑思维将无法发挥作用。所以，我们想要做的是帮助客户感到被倾听、被看见、被认可、被重视。我们不想逃跑。
We're going to break for a quick break here and I'll be back afterwards to talk with you more about how we can recognize and work with risk as aspiring psychologists. Thank you. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Hi, I'm Max and I work as an assistant psychologist in the Learning Disability Service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that end goal in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book The Clinical Psychologist Collective and decided that this would be a great buy for me to help me on my journey.
我们在这里休息一下，稍后回来，继续与大家探讨作为有志心理学家，我们如何识别和处理风险。谢谢。就在这本书里。它是《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。我是Max，我在西约克郡的学习障碍服务部门担任助理心理学家。像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在缓慢而坚定地朝着那个看似不可能的目标——进入临床博士课程——努力。考虑到这个最终目标，我想看看市面上有什么书可以提供帮助。我发现了Marianne的《临床心理学家集体》，并决定这对我的旅程来说是一个很好的购买选择。
I found Marianne's book really informative and most insightful. I especially liked how the stories reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist and that as long as you have good interpersonal skills such as compassion and empathy you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists and also those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and maybe want to work in that field one day if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified.
我发现Marianne的书非常有信息量，也最有洞察力。我特别喜欢书中的故事，它们让我确信，成为一名心理学家并不需要学术上完美，只要你拥有良好的社交技能，如同情心和共情能力，你就能达到目标。我强烈向所有有志心理学家，以及那些想更多了解临床心理学世界并可能希望有一天在该领域工作的人推荐这本书。如果你正在寻求成为一名心理学家，那么就让这本书成为你的指南，书中充满了将帮助你获得资格的经验教训。
So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Okay, welcome back. So before we broke, we were thinking about what risk is, what it might look like, what it might involve and how we can try to optimally respond. It's important that you are able to get information about what people are telling you because it might be that you need to communicate that accurately to other services as well. It might be that you are going to need to summon an ambulance or you are going to need to summon police um coast guard you know it might be that you need to call
所以来看看吧。就在这本书里。它是《临床心理学家集体》。好了，欢迎回来。在休息之前，我们一直在思考什么是风险，它可能是什么样子，它可能涉及什么，以及我们如何尝试做出最佳反应。重要的是，你要能够获取关于人们告诉你的信息，因为你可能需要准确地将其传达给其他服务机构。你可能需要叫救护车，或者你需要叫警察、海岸警卫队，你可能需要拨打
the railways emergency line um is it transport police i think it's transport police but a quick google will reveal who the right people to contact are. I believe there's a specific telephone line for if someone has suggested that they are going to attempt to end their own life on the railway. And what I will do is I will try and dig that out and put that in the show notes for you. When I was working in the NHS, we were given like a little card to have on our keys, which gave the number, but it snapped off. And so I don't have it anymore. But there is a specific number that you can call. So I will try my best to get hold of that. Yeah, pop it in your diary because it might be really useful. So I have always, when working in clinical roles, at the front of my diary, I have had important numbers, including the crisis team, including Samaritans, including, you know, numbers such as, you know, transport police and, you know, any relevant people in your area that help in crisis situations, because it really could make the difference if you're having to scrabble around and look for a
铁路紧急电话。我想是交通警察，但我认为快速谷歌一下就能知道该联系谁。我相信如果有人暗示他们打算在铁路上结束自己的生命，有一个专门的电话专线。我会尽力把它找出来，放在节目说明里给你。当我在NHS工作时，我们钥匙上有一个小卡片，上面有这个号码，但它断了。所以我没有了。但有一个你可以拨打的特定号码。所以我将尽我所能找到它。是的，把它记在你的日记里，因为它可能真的很有用。所以，在担任临床职务时，我总是会在日记的首页记下重要的号码，包括危机小组、撒玛利亚会，包括交通警察，以及你所在地区在危机情况下提供帮助的相关人员，因为如果你不得不手忙脚乱地寻找
number in a moment where actually there isn't much time. It's much better to be able to open up your diary, get to where you need to be and respond. So take a little bit of moments, especially if you're setting up a new diary for the year or you're setting up in a new role. You know, get a little bit of an idea of what do I do if the worst happens? What do I do if something happens that means I need to take immediate safeguarding actions? So it might be that you've got your local adult or child safeguarding contact details in your important phone number section. They would be very useful ones for you to have indeed. indeed so yeah a little bit of time in advance of when you're going to need this information
号码，而实际上时间并不多，这真的会产生很大的不同。能够打开日记，找到你需要的地方并做出反应要好得多。所以，花一点时间，特别是如果你正在为新的一年准备新日记，或者你正在担任新职务。了解一下“如果最坏的情况发生，我该怎么办？”“如果发生了一些事情，意味着我需要立即采取保障行动，我该怎么办？”所以，你可能在重要电话号码部分有当地成人或儿童保障的联系方式。这些确实是你非常有用的信息。
is absolutely time well spent in my opinion when we are getting to know clients it can be useful to think about screening for risk so there are of course specific screening measures that you can use i tend to when it's generic just use the core outcome measure because it does screen for risk and it will tell you whether someone is clinically significant for risk or not so that's a really useful place to start but of course things like the GAD7 and the PHQ9 they also screen a little bit for risk as well but yeah it's an idea to monitor risk so you know it can be useful to do before during and after measures so your before might happen at assessment your during might happen you know at the point that you start therapy or mid therapy and then depending on how long your intervention is you might want to repeat those measures as well and then obviously have measures
在我看来，在需要这些信息之前花一点时间绝对是值得的。当我们开始了解客户时，考虑进行风险筛查是有用的。当然，有一些特定的筛查工具你可以使用。当情况一般时，我倾向于使用核心结果测量（CORE Outcome Measure），因为它确实会筛查风险，并会告诉你某人的风险是否具有临床意义。所以这是一个很好的起点。当然，像GAD7和PHQ9这样的工具也会对风险进行一些筛查。但是的，监测风险是一个好主意，所以你可以在测量之前、期间和之后进行。你的“之前”可能发生在评估时，“期间”可能发生在开始治疗或治疗中期，然后根据你的干预时间长短，你可能也想重复这些测量，然后显然在
again at the close but what we'd be hoping for is that with whatever brilliant work that you and your team are doing, that their well-being improves, their problems decrease, their functioning gets better. And of course, their risk decreases. That is, you know, the gold standard for what I would think of as a piece of work well done indeed. And of course, you know, what we've covered in the boundary setting episode of the podcast is, well, what happens if it's only really after you have the session that you, you know, your cogs start whirring or you piece together something that you hadn't really picked up on in the session or you suddenly think well actually now I've discussed that with my supervisor that does feel a lot riskier than I felt it was at the
结束时再次进行测量。但我们希望的是，通过你和你的团队所做的出色工作，他们的幸福感得到改善，问题减少，功能变得更好。当然，他们的风险也会降低。这就是我认为的一项出色工作的黄金标准。当然，我们在播客的界限设定那一期中讨论过，如果是在会谈之后，你的大脑才开始转动，或者你拼凑出了一些你在会谈中没有真正注意到的事情，或者你突然想到“实际上，现在我和我的督导讨论过之后，这感觉比我当时感觉的风险要大得多”，
time you know what do we do then And it might be that you're needing to access safeguarding or refer to safeguarding or activate, you know, a keep safe plan without getting hold of the client if in fact you haven't been able to get hold of them. And if you haven't been able to get hold of them that's further evidence that we need to put our keep safe plan in place. Now most services that I'm aware of ought to have care plans so it's hopefully something that you're familiar with and it might be something that all of your multidisciplinary team feed into as well so there might be care planning elements from psychiatry there might be care planning elements from from a care coordinator or from you know occupational therapy for example and you might well be able to feed into that as well with any work that you've
我们该怎么办？你可能需要联系保障部门，或转介给保障部门，或者在无法联系到客户的情况下激活安全计划。如果你无法联系到他们，这进一步证明我们需要实施我们的安全计划。现在，我所知道的大多数服务机构都应该有护理计划，所以希望这是你熟悉的东西，而且这可能是你的多学科团队都会参与的事情。所以，精神科可能会有护理计划要素，护理协调员或职业治疗师可能会有护理计划要素，你也可以通过你所做的任何工作来参与其中。
been doing so care planning is where we are getting a sense of what might be useful and how we're going to achieve that. But elements of risk would be covered there as well. And in your individual trust or environment, there will likely be risk screening tools and risk screening measures that go into the care planning process. So I'm trying to think what the name of my clinical note software was called in the nhs it was either epex or lorenzo and i can't for the life of me i think it was epex the most recent one um it's only just under a year ago you know fallen straight out of my head or was it care notes i think it was care notes so yeah I think there's three different genesis's there of epex lorenzo and care notes and I've also used rio as well but these clinical notes systems will often have um you know ways to to specifically screen for and manage
所以，护理计划是我们了解什么是有用的以及我们将如何实现这一目标的过程。但风险要素也会涵盖在其中。在你所在的信托机构或环境中，可能会有风险筛查工具和风险筛查措施进入护理计划过程。我正在努力回想我在NHS的临床记录软件的名字，是Epex还是Lorenzo，我记不清了，我想是Epex，最近的一个。这只是不到一年前的事，我竟然完全忘记了，还是Care Notes？我想是Care Notes。所以，我想Epex、Lorenzo和Care Notes有三种不同的起源，我也用过Rio，但这些临床记录系统通常会有
risk so do check out your organizational practices as well but so to summarize you know what we've done in today's podcast episode is we've thought about risk to selves risk to others and ways to manage record and monitor that risk it's also useful to think about whether self-harm always means, you know, suicide. And when we're working with adolescent population and we're working with parents of adolescents, sometimes it can be helpful to just separate those two actions a little bit. So if you've got a young person who's cutting, for example, but cutting in a superficial way, then it doesn't always
专门筛查和管理风险的方法。所以，也要检查一下你们组织的实践。总之，我们在今天的播客节目中思考了对自己构成的风险、对他人的风险，以及管理、记录和监测这些风险的方法。思考自残是否总是意味着自杀也很有用。当我们与青少年群体合作，以及与青少年的父母合作时，有时将这两个行为稍微分开是有帮助的。所以，如果你有一个正在自残的年轻人，例如，但自残的方式是表层的，那么这并不总是
necessarily equate that that client is suicidal so sometimes it can be useful to you know with the client's consent share that with the family you know actually the client the client has told me or you know you might you might I've sometimes fed that back with a young person in the room at the same time as their parent actually you know so and so is not suicidal they're not feeling suicidal but they are feeling you know a bit lost or a bit wobbly and they're finding that this helps them have some control at the moment and of course what we want to do is move towards being able to learn skills to you know ameliorate this distress you know so that they can have control in different ways so you know sometimes having that conversation with people can be useful and of course what we know is that people who do self-harm
必然等同于该客户有自杀倾向。所以有时在客户同意的情况下，与家人分享这一点是有用的。实际上，客户告诉我……或者你可能……我有时会在年轻人和他们的父母同时在场的情况下反馈这一点。实际上，某某人并没有自杀倾向，他们没有自杀的想法，但他们感到有点迷茫或有点动摇，他们发现这在目前能帮助他们获得一些控制感。当然，我们想要做的是朝着能够学习技能来缓解这种痛苦的方向努力，这样他们就可以通过不同的方式获得控制感。所以，有时与人们进行这种对话是有用的。当然，我们知道自残的人
are more likely to go on to have you know know, suicidal thoughts or intentions, but it's not always the case. So, you know, we can't be resting on our laurels here and guaranteeing that, you know, that someone is not going to become suicidal, but currently at the point of assessment, if that is indeed what you are assessing, it looks like there is no suicidal intent currently. Oh, people, this is big stuff, isn't it? This is important stuff. And you are out there doing this work or you will be in future. And it matters, you know, it matters to you, it matters to clients that you may be working with currently. It matters to clients who you may not even have met yet. It matters to clients who may be out there living their best life right now. But when they need you, you will be there and you will have that theory and practice ready to roll to help make that
更有可能产生自杀的想法或意图，但这并不总是事实。所以，我们不能在这里高枕无忧，保证某人不会产生自杀倾向。但在评估时，如果这确实是你正在评估的内容，看起来目前没有自杀意图。哦，伙计们，这是大事，不是吗？这是重要的事情。你正在外面做这项工作，或者将来会做。这很重要，这对你很重要，对你目前可能正在合作的客户很重要。这对你甚至还没见过的客户很重要。这对那些现在可能正在过着最好生活的客户很重要。但当他们需要你时，你会在那里，你将准备好理论和实践来帮助做出
difference and that is so incredible well done to you and thank you for listening to this episode I hope you find it useful like I said it was a special request so if you've got any special requests of your own, then do go and check out the podcast section of my website, goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast to submit your special requests. I hope you find the upcoming information on the compassionate Q&A. You can watch, depending on when you're listening to this, you can definitely watch the first one and by the time this comes out you might well be able to watch the second one on replay as well
改变，这真是太不可思议了。做得好，感谢你收听这一期节目。我希望你觉得它有用。正如我所说，这是一个特别请求，所以如果你有自己的特别请求，请务必查看我网站上的播客部分，goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast 来提交你的特别请求。我希望你觉得即将到来的关于同情问答（Compassionate Q&A）的信息有用。你可以观看，取决于你什么时候收听，你绝对可以观看第一个，当这期节目发布时，你可能也可以观看第二个的回放。
the easiest way to do that is by heading to good thinking psychological services on youtube whilst you're there be rude not to you might as well like and subscribe you know subscribe to the channel like all the, fling a few comments in. It would be so welcomed. Thank you for listening and I hope you find the content useful. I'll look forward to catching up with you next week. Don't forget that new episodes land at 6 a.m. on a Monday, UK time. So subscribe via podcast channels and that's when they'll drop into your podcast library or
最简单的方法是前往YouTube上的“Good Thinking Psychological Services”。既然去了，不妨点赞和订阅，订阅频道，点赞所有内容，发表一些评论。这将非常受欢迎。感谢你的收听，希望你觉得内容有用。我期待下周与你见面。别忘了新节目在英国时间周一早上6点发布。所以通过播客频道订阅，它们就会出现在你的播客库中，或者
just go searching for them at 6am on a Monday and be hot off the press. Take care, have a lovely day, whatever you're up to. And again, thank you for being part of my world. Thank you again for being part of my world and for listening right to the end we've just got a little bit coming up about the compassionate q and a series and then you can enjoy the jingle take care and like i said if you'd like to get involved with your own story for the aspiring psychologist collective then do check out the details in the show notes for how you can request more information. But if you head to my website, which is goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk
在周一早上6点搜索它们，抢先收听。保重，祝你度过愉快的一天，无论你在做什么。再次感谢你成为我世界的一部分。再次感谢你成为我世界的一部分，并一直听到最后。我们接下来有一点关于同情问答系列的内容，然后你可以享受片头曲。保重，正如我所说，如果你想为《有志心理学家集体》贡献你自己的故事，请查看节目说明中的详细信息，了解如何请求更多信息。但如果你前往我的网站，即 goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk
and then head to my books, there will be information there for you. Being well supported during any interview season is so important. I have therefore planned some compassionate question and answer support sessions for you. You are absolutely welcome to come along to all of them, some of them, none of them. No need to book and here are the dates for you monday the 28th of february from 7 30 p.m monday the 21st of march 7 30 p.m monday the 4th of april 7 30 p.m and monday the 9th of may 7 30 p.m and they will all be
然后前往我的书籍页面，那里会有相关信息。在任何面试季得到良好的支持是非常重要的。因此，我为你计划了一些同情问答支持会议。非常欢迎你参加所有、部分或不参加。无需预约，以下是日期：2月28日星期一晚上7:30，3月21日星期一晚上7:30，4月4日星期一晚上7:30，以及5月9日星期一晚上7:30。它们都将
live streaming via my socials which includes Twitter, YouTube, LinkedIn and Facebook so you can absolutely pick your favourite platform and they'll all be available on replay as well. Hope you find it so useful and I will look forward to catching up with some of you then. Take care. to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast
通过我的社交媒体进行直播，包括Twitter、YouTube、LinkedIn和Facebook，所以你可以绝对选择你喜欢的平台，它们也都会提供回放。希望你觉得它非常有用，我期待到时候与你们中的一些人见面。保重。如果你正在寻求成为一名心理学家，那么就让这个播客成为你的指南，陪伴你走上获得资格认证的道路。这里是《有志心理学家播客》，
with Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you
我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，我是一名实习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。成为临床心理学家的途径之多让我感到惊讶，成为一名临床心理学家并没有完美的途径，这让我充满了信心，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就停不下来。
start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。